[Music]
the bouquet of bell shaped organisms you
see in the middle of the screen right
now our voor de cèlle
in their youth these protists are
swimmers moving around to gather food
and grow but as adults vorticella
like to settle down using their long
stalks to attach to bits of rock algae
or even animals of course sometimes
multiple vorticella find the same prime
real estate but when you're small it's
easy to share space and that is why
you'll find groups of vorticella
like this one it's not technically a
colony think of it more as a community
of like-minded individuals and today we
are going to join them they may not seem
to have the most exciting lifestyle I
hear that but even in the micro cosmos
constancy comes with its own small
thrills so today we're gonna stick with
these Vortice Ella for 12 minutes of
unedited footage and get to know them
better while also meeting some of their
strange visitors we've been visited
several times now by this delightfully
blue blob that kind of resembles a whale
thanks to its relatively large size and
Oceanic you of course it is not a whale
but it is one of our favourite Giants of
the micro cosmos Stentor karolius leg
vorticella tenders are ciliates
and while this denter is swimming freely
they are known to attach to surfaces as
well these attached centers will take on
the distinctive trumpet shape that they
are known and named for making them look
like a larger more exaggerated form of
the Vorta Stella's bell shape
[Music]
one of the striking movements you'll
notice happening again and again is that
rapid contraction of the vorticella
whenever they are touched this movement
is likely a protective maneuver allowing
the organisms to evade predators and
adapt to turbulent waters this movement
is created by a thin fiber inside the
stock called the my own eeem which
contracts rapidly into a coil this
movement is very fast as you probably
have been witnessing but watch carefully
and you might be able to see some of
those tight coils as the Vorta çelik
contract and relax again
[Music]
in the upper left corner here you can
see what looks like a cross between a
spider and the Millennium Falcon now
again it is of course neither of those
things this is a knop leus when otto
friedrich muller first observed the
knobblies in the 18th century he thought
it was its own species just one of those
strange adult organisms of the micro
cosmos but eventually scientists
understood that this organism is
actually the early larval stage of some
kind of crustacean and in about a minute
we will see one of the crustaceans it
might grow up to become
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this crustacean is a cyclops one of the
possible creatures that the earlier
knotless might eventually grow into the
inspiration for its name is obvious what
else could you name an organism that
only has one large eye the Cyclops of
the micro cosmos is as we will see a bit
obtrusive but it is relatively harmless
to us that is until and unless they
become hosts to parasites like the
guinea worm which can do harm to humans
[Music]
[Music]
returning our attention to the Fortis
sella while their adult forms don't move
around much they are still able to
gather food ranging from bacteria to
smaller protists they do this using the
cilia around their mouth waving around
the small hair like structures to create
currents that will drive food into their
mouths
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you may have noticed some smaller
organisms swimming around in grazing
amongst the Vorta gsella many of these
are rotifers trying to find the green
algae you can also see zooming around or
you can see them munching on the
bacteria and fungi that form the biofilm
that the vorticella have attached
themselves to it is always so strange to
realize that rotifers are multicellular
animals while vorticella are
single-celled organisms and yet rotifers
are usually smaller than their
structurally simpler neighbors
[Music]
[Music]
like other microbes vorticella are found
in aquatic habitats all over the world
but in 2012 a group of scientists found
evidence of a vorticella in a very
strange location inside the 200 million
year old fossil of a leech cocoon from
Antarctica yes
the vorticella like organism was also
long dead preserved in the
polysaccharides and fibrous proteins
that made up the prehistoric cocoon
ciliates may be easy for us to find in
our own microscope samples but these
kinds of fossilized remains are much
more rare because their soft bodies make
for bad fossils the uniqueness of this
kind of discovery is matched by just how
striking the similarities are between
the fossilized organism the scientists
found and the modern-day vortice le you
can see here even in the fossil you can
make out the distinct bell-shaped body
and helical stalk that's so closely
resemble these verticillium right now
before our eyes
[Music]
I don't know much about microbial
etiquette but this Cyclops does seem
kind of rude like it's just trying to
push its way through the floor to
sellout then again maybe the vorticella
are the rude ones taking up all this
space or maybe we shouldn't be pushing
our human sense of etiquette on the
microbes whatever the answer the
vorticella seem to be holding their own
quite well here while the Vorta cell it
contracted tightly in response to the
Cyclops earlier you can now watch as
they extend back to their normal
configuration you might even see some of
the tight coils in their stalks in the
moments before they relax
[Music]
varta sella were first described by the
creator of the microscope Antony van
Leeuwenhoek himself in 1674 but you know
who doesn't care about that distinction
this Cyclops who is back for round two
[Music]
for all the smaller organisms that dart
in and out and for all the larger
organisms that rudely barrel through
them the vorticella
just rolls with the punches after 12
minutes of this starting to feel like
maybe I could learn a thing or two from
these little troopers thank you for
coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us and thank you especially to all of
these people who support this show on
patreon they are the reason this small
team of people can make this show and we
are really happy and grateful to be able
to do it if you'd like to join them you
can go to patreon.com/scishow
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James you can check out
Jam and germs on Instagram and if you
want to see more from us there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere
nearby